une quarantaine de témoins se sont
relayés à la barre
Donald Williams était présent sur place
il a alerté la police il estimait qu'il
assistait à une tentative de meurtre
moment fort du procès le témoignage à
visage couvert de darnella qui n'avait
que 17 ans au moment du drame c'est elle
qui avait filmé la vidéo virale de
l'arrestation la jeune fille a affirmé
au jury qu'elle était toujours hantée
parce qu'elle avait vu
quand je regarde George Floyd je vois
mon père je vois mes frères mes cousins
mes oncles parce qu'ils sont tous noirs
l'usage de la force était au coeur du
procès Derek Chauvin avait-il enfin les
règles lorsqu'il a posé son genou sur le
coup de George Floyd le témoignage des
policiers a été révélateur
ce n'est pas conforme à nos règles ce
n'est pas ce que nous enseignons et cela
ne doit pas être tolérée
pour ce lieutenant rien ne justifiait un
tel usage de force
et mettre son genou sur le coup aussi
longtemps c'est injustifié
je n'ai vu aucune raison pour les
officiers de se sentir en danger
les témoignages des experts médicaux ont
aussi accablé des rectch ovins selon eux
ce sont les pressions exercées par le
genou du policier qui ont entraîné la
mort de George Floyd
il ne s'agit pas d'une mort soudaine par
arrêt cardiaque il s'agit d'une mort où
le cœur et les poumons ont cessé
fonctionner et la cause en est l'usage
excessif de la force par le policier la
contention et la compression
[Applaudissements]
des preuves accablantes qui ont permis
au jury de rendre un verdict unanime de
culpabilité après seulement 10 heures de
délibération
ici à Radio-Canada Montréal